القمه رساله التحدي بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده ولحلفائها في المنطقه وابعد لنرى
معا الى هذه هذا الرسم اذا الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي انتقل عبر القطار على مدى اذا
1500 كيلو متر لينتقل هنا في منطقه في
سيبيريا في منطقه فراديفوس ستوك حيث تم
اللقاء خلال ساعتين واكثر وكان لافتا او
لافته هي هذه الصوره من قاعده فضائيه
قاعده
التي تعتبر فخرا روسيا لجهه اخر التقنيات
الحديثه في مجال الفضاء هذه الرساله
معناها بان موسكو باتت منفتحه على احتمال
مد دوله تعتبرها الامم المتحده مارقه بكل
التكنولوجيا الفضائيه وايضا التكنولوجيا
التي على اطلاق المزيد من الصواريخ
الباليستيه وهو امر محظور عندما تفعل ذلك
فان موسكو تعرض نفسها لان تشجع اذا
الانتشار النووي وهي يعني خلافا لمقررات
الامم المتحده فاذا
كوريا الشماليه معنيه بتحديث ترسنتها
العسكريه خاصه وانها تعود الى فتره
الاتحاد السوفيتي معنيه بالحصول على
التكنولوجيا الاقمار الصناعيه خاصه وانها
فشلت مرتين في ارسال او وضع قمر تجسس على
مدار الارض ومعنيه ايضا بالغواصات العامله
بالطاقه النوويه
لمجابهات خصومها خاصه في بحر اليابان في
هذا الصدد الرئيس بوتين ابقى على الغموض
في تصريحاته هو لم يقل بانه
سيبرم اتفاقا عسكريا مع كوري الشماليه
ولكنه قال بان هناك امكانيات للتعاون وركز
على بناء الاقمار الصناعيه وبالمقابل
روسيا مستعده او مهتمه جدا بالتزود
بالذخائر الكوريه الشماليه خاصه وانها
تقول المصادر العسكريه المراقبين
العسكريين يقولون بانها
توائموا الترسانه الروسيه او الاسلحه
الروسيه هذه خاصه في القذائف المدفعيه
المضاده للدبابات والتي يمكنها من خلالها
اي روسيا ان تكسر تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه
بعد عشرين شهرا من هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه
حرب الاستنزاف التي تستنزف المعدات
الروسيه لكن هناك حديث وهنا نرى بان
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي يقف
مع روسيا في هذه الحرب ويتبنى روايتها
ويصف الحرب في اوكرانيا بانها تجمع للشر
في اشاره الى انها حرب بالوكاله تقودها
الولايات المتحده وحلف شمال الاطلسي وحلف
شمال الاطلسي كما تقول موسكو اليوم
الرساله الابرز هو ان هذا اللقاء او هذا
التعاون بين دولتين اصبحتا معزولتين على
الساحه الدوليه
مساله رابح رابح بالنسبه للطرفين لكن هناك
خبراء يتساءلون هل لكوريا الشماليه كل
الامكانيات لتصدير الذخائر خاصه وانها
ترزح تحت العقوبات منذ العام 2006 وهل
روسيا مستعده
للتفريط في كل
يعني
مبادئها على الساحه الدوليه مقابل هذا
الحلف السؤال يطرح نفسه وكذلك هناك حسابات
اخرى هذا الحلف هو يقابل الحلف الامريكي
الكوري الجنوبي والياباني في بحر اليابان
كما انه يفتح امام كوريا الشماليه متنفسا
امام روسيا بالمقابل مع انحصار علاقتها مع
الصين وبالنسبه لروسيا فانها تبعث ايضا
برساله الى كوريا الجنوبيه التي تعد ابرز
من يمول اوكرانيا بالاسلحه عن طريق بولندا
فاذا العلاقه
معقده والرسائل كثيره ولكنها تصب في اتجاه
واحد وهو الردع بنسبه للطرف المقابل في
الحرب الاوكرانيه كل الشكر الجزيل الكرامه